i'm so sorry i can't talk right now
we're shooting the final days of my life
i've been given a second chance at life
so one of the things that really came
through
is um that love you have for that little
boy yours arthur will always be my north
star so i mean he just whether he's the
a cutie a good kid a bad kid any of it
it'll always be for him
don't worry i know what i'm doing
introducing selma blair gives an
intimate look inside the 49 year old
struggle after being diagnosed with ms
in 2018. cameras followed selma for
months documenting everything from her
home life to the emotional moment now
ten-year-old son arthur shaved off all
her hair before a stem cell treatment
why did you decide to have him do that i
asked him before i said is there
anything that makes you nervous about me
going away to chicago and doing this he
said i don't want you to lose your hair
and i said well then i'll just have you
cut it so it's not so surprising to you
it was to have him be part of it to help
be in control of
um maybe like a first image of mom
looking different
the meds are just making me feel worse
i'm sick today
rachel you know you directed this but
just watching it back were there
things that stood out to you um watching
the footage of her in the hospital
during the 19 days of isolation the
images of her and the pain that she
experienced during that time that really
hit me selma is such a generous person
in so many ways
she's also hilariously funny i feel like
a little tom hanks maybe where he's
stranded on an island
and i'm eating wilson
it's that sense of humor that's helped
selma navigate living with a
neurological disease that sometimes
affects her ability to walk and speak
but despite taking a step back from
hollywood selma revealed she desires to
return to acting i definitely have gone
through
a good 10 15 years really since hellboy
2 wrapped um of not really finding my
way and not really feeling well i
absolutely love acting i i love being a
part of these sets but i'm not saying oh
i'm i'm done but i know the reality you
know i i went through a lot i have
things to recover and it would have to
find
a fit on the right on the right terms
and to be important or else i'll just
continue to
you know kind of find more pathways in
this town
one step on selma's path to finding
peace with her situation is when she got
back on the horse
literally baby steps you know you don't
get to ride into the sunset but you know
put it yet
but it's still to be back on him i mean
animals play a huge
huge love this is really a step of like
no i am making this change with the end
of life what we have
[Music]
you